[Music]
remember that first year before the
season started for the vegas gold
knights and the sports books had the
team at 500-1 to win the stanley cup
and then the knights kept beating those
odds a lot of sportsbook directors were
sweating bullets as they won the
division
won the western conference and made it
to the ultimate series the stanley cup
final
now after only three years of existence
the vegas golden knights are the odds-on
favorite to win the stanley cup in year
four
over the sports book at westgate they
have the knights as a team to beat this
year at six to one
then the lightning at 7-1 avalanche 8-1
heading into this year
they're the favorites because alex
petrangelo is now a golden knight
yeah so we opened up the 1971 to win the
title
they made acquisition uh a player from
the blues
uh pete tarangelo and uh we moved them
down to six one now they're the
the main favorite for the pool they're
already a solid team
and then that acquisition just made
their stock rise
and you know people being from las vegas
people are looking to bet the knights so
that number is also based off of
anticipation of what bets are going to
come in
now if you're looking at just the west
how the west has won vegas the favorite
at three to one then colorado seven to
two
dallas st louis and vancouver are all 10
to one
your las vegas raiders are coming off a
big bye week and lo and behold the team
they're facing
is coming off a big win tom brady and
the tampa bay buccaneers are coming into
town huge test for
the raiders what's so disappointing to
everybody though from the owner all the
way down to the players and
all the raider nation is it it's not a
normal year and fans won't be able to
enjoy this game
but someday las vegas fans and those
from all across the country
will be back in their silver and black
to
be able to represent this city a little
bit you know hopefully
eventually we'll be able to get those
fans and you know some of the
las vegas people in there as well as
greater nation from across the country
you know
it's going to be unbelievable that
atmosphere all right it was the game
this afternoon kansas city chiefs coming
off that loss to the raiders back on the
field a covid induced tuesday afternoon
game in buffalo
kc doing what it does best mahomes to
kelsey that was money it is again today
they hooked up twice buffalo made a game
of it but the wizardry of patrick
mahomes just too much and the chiefs
beat the bills
26-17 unf football team is gearing up
for an historic opener inside a legion
stadium
they will face reno october 31st we know
the time now 7
30. the team has already been working
out inside that facility they can't
look ahead though because they've got a
game still to play a road game
before they christen that new home vegas
meets san diego state
saturday in carson california
we've started to try to plant some seeds
in in our identity and our principles
and the way we communicate
and uh now we move on to game week and
we start trying to focus
uh as fast as we can on another opponent
all the while still trying to uh really
you know lay the ground to work for what
we're trying to do in a new program
hey everybody's raving about the pga
stop at shadow creek this past weekend
the golf course is one of the most
exclusive in the world and for many
players it was their first experience at
shadow creek
and another first the broadcast
promoting a betting app bet
mgm during the event that's certainly
the future of sports betting
so this is a quick prop bet put up by
bett mgm
who will win just this 18th hole between
these two guys
it's just a really unique opportunity we
couldn't forego and so for us to
showcase the core is something we've had
a great deal of pride in for the last 30
years
is just fantastic for us and so we're
just excited to be out here and hosting
oh it is so beautiful out there myself
also mentioned here the world series
begins tomorrow the dodgers
acting as host for game one against the
tampa bay rays in arlington texas
in front of a limited number of fans
denise such a big win for las vegas with
that golf tournament now that mention
good stuff